Thank you.
Hello everyone.
Hi, hi, hi.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hi welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome back to CraftMine.
Woo woo woo!
Yippee.
Hello, hello, hello.
Yes.
Welcome.
How is Minky feeling?
I'm... 6 out of 10.
You're a blessing.
Of course.
Thank you so much for the 5 gift.
Before I get too much in, you guys.
It has been shown.
I have this Friday... This Friday, I have my first ever Gamersupps merch drop.
And they just now showed the design.
So I'm going to show you guys.
No skip a ad.
Are you guys ready?
Oh wait.
I did it the wrong way.
It's supposed to be the front on the...
On the... On the left side.
It's fine.
Whatever.
Look at that.
Wowee.
And then... And then you see the parts that are like kind of mint?
Whatever you... Whatever drink you have in there.
If it's red or blue or green or...
Whatever color...
Um... It changes the colors... As well.
So it's a little...
Customizable Minto.
Yeah.
And then... And then you can also get the design...
Brrrrr... As a t-shirt!
Whoa...
Actually... The t-shirt is so much more soft than I imagined.
It's actually so nice.
I got mine...
A while ago.
I wear it to bed.
So, yeah.
I'm gonna wear that in public.
You totally can!
Or you could wear it anywhere.
You can wear it!
Nyah!
No spamming, please!
Yes, yes, yes!
And then also... Oops, I didn't mean to get rid of it.
And then also, there is a... A mouse pad!
Where I am skateboarding!
And it's so cool!
Wow!
Even though I never skateboard before.
I'm a bit of a...
But, I did inline skating.
Which I like heat better, to be honest.
But, made skateboarding is like the thing.
And if you like the skateboard, you can get your own... Oh, sorry.
The size.
You can get your own fingerboard!
Whoa!
Wowee!
So, you can... You can do sick tricks with your Mito fingerboard!
Yeah!
Yeah, so I have some merch coming out on Friday.
Of course, I'll...
Thank you!
But also, I couldn't... I couldn't... When they sent me the design, I couldn't pass up... Like, look.
I couldn't pass up on the... The idea of being able to change the panty color.
Like, I was like, wait a second.
That's so genius!
Like, at first, they had it where it was just white.
And I was like, wait.
Can you make it see-through?
So that... Because originally, I was gonna be like, ah, maybe I don't want my butt out on a cup.
But then I was like... I was like, wait.
But if you make it see-through, then you can change the panty colors.
And so I was like, can you do that?
And they were like, yeah.
I was like, yeah!
And you can put any drink in there as well.
You could drink orange juice.
You could drink... You could drink any kind of drink.
You could drink... You could drink... Mountain Dew.
One board for each finger.
Yeah, my see-through panty.
That's very ghosty, you know?
You could do milk.
Yeah, you could.
But then they would just be white.
The freak overpowered the embarrassment.
It's true.
Yeah.
Baja Blast.
That would actually look so good, no?
Strawberry milk?
See?
You guys are cooking now.
You guys are cooking.
So if you could purchase your very own Minky Cup, that would be very awesome.
And helpful to me as well.
Yeah!
And for everybody who has used my code BOOMERONGAMERSUP so far, thank you, guys.
Thank you very, very, very much.
Really appreciate it.
Do I get a Minto Desk Mat or a 2B one?
Well, if you're asking me, I'd say Minto Desk Mat.
I don't think 2B will tell you to get a 2B Desk Mat.
But I can say, Kamori Asani, thank you for the super chat.
And also, you should get the Minto Desk Mat.
Because I'm directly telling you to your face right now.
No!
Yeah!
To be or not to be.
Definitely not to be.
Get that out of there.
You're so right!
Yeah!
So this will all be up on Friday.
So...
And if you're embarrassed about the back of the shirt, you can always wear a jacket.
But don't be embarrassed.
Let your freak flag fly, baby.
Oh, and then...
You can kind of see it here.
The front says, And then, the other side says, So, it's very maid-like and proper.
And look!
Look, the little wisp has even a bandana.
It's so cute.
So...
Mm-hmm.
Very proper.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He does!
It's so cute, no?
So...
Mm.
Um...
Yeah!
So...
Good...
Friday.
But today...
Mine...
Uh, Craft Mine.
Craft Mine.
So I did Craft Mine...
Uh...
Last time...
I want to play...
I wanted to play just a little bit more.
Since it was, like, you know...
But I think I...
I think I'm, like, in a...
Random place.
I think I'm in, like, a mine.
Last time I left off.
And I have to find the exit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I got, like, caught up.
So we gotta find the exit to this place.
I gotta get some...
I gotta get some stuff.
Is this like Minecraft?
Yes, but it's Craft Mine.
It's, like...
So different.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yes!
My pickaxe swinging from side to side.
Oh!
So...
So we back in the mine.
Swinging my pickaxe from side to side.
That's what I'm doing.
Wait, maybe we stick with one tree.
Open our Minecraft mood.
Maybe I need to play some Craft Mine.
It's enough...
It's a different enough of an experience that it feels...
Different and new and fun.
You know what I mean?
Although, I don't remember how to do much.
So...
I'm gonna have to remember how to play this.
Let's see.
Okay, so...
For those who didn't see last week...
See how things are kinda weird, no?
We...
Have to...
Oh, and I have to unlock things.
But I don't remember...
Was it V?
No.
You?
Yes, you is up a grade.
I'm from Colombia.
Is it possible...
To get them...
Mouse Phantom Pad?
Suikyo!
I...
I don't know...
Um...
That's a...
Gamersubs question.
Because they're the ones shipping it.
So...
Um...
Honestly...
Unfortunately, I can't...
Like, I don't know where they ship to.
But I feel like they probably...
Would ship there.
Maybe.
So...
Each...
So basically...
In Craft Mine...
You craft...
Your own mine...
Oh yeah!
I have Double Jump!
I forgot!
You craft your own mine...
And then...
You have to...
Find the escape.
So currently...
I have tried to...
Escape.
Can you hear me...
Jumping...
With my keyboard?
Wow!
Double Jump is crazy!
You can't!
Oh, that's so funny.
Clacka clacka!
Oh, you can?
Haha!
And then...
I think it also...
It does help with...
Fall damage.
Oh my god!
Crazy!
Ouch!
Nevermind!
Um...
Oh no!
It's starting to get dark!
Wait!
Um...
One thing about this...
Is you can't sleep in the game...
Unless I have like no...
I have no food!
Oh golly!
Okay!
Um...
Let's do some upgrades...
While I'm on the ice...
Oh!
I only have three levels!
Uh oh!
Nevermind!
I can't do any upgrades!
Literally not...
I think a single thing!
Oh wait!
I could do...
Increase my luck while fishing?
I can't do anything!
Nevermind!
Let's not upgrade!
Let's survive the night!
Let's...
Uh...
Make ourselves a sword?
What?
So basically...
I had to unlock the ability...
To be able to...
Make these things...
Or make a crafting table...
You have to unlock abilities...
In this version...
It's very strange...
Oh!
I can make a boat!
That would be good too!
Especially because...
I don't know recipes...
So it was very hard at first...
For me to...
Understand this...
Your Oshimike was talking about Chicken Jockey...
Yes!
I watched that...
Matt...
I watched...
Red Letter Media...
And I watched...
Him talk about Chicken Jockey...
But they left the movie theater early...
They like got...
So...
Red Letter Media...
My Oshimike's...
Mike's the Closso...
They talked about the Minecraft movie...
And I kind of agree with his opinion...
In that...
So basically...
He was like...
I'm fine...
With...
The chaos that is happening...
At the movie theaters...
Which...
I don't agree with that part...
I think it's...
You know...
You don't have to make a mess...
For the...
For the poor employees...
But...
Oh my god!
We found it!
Let's go!
But...
His thing was kind of like...
You know...
Whatever gets...
More people going back to the movie theaters...
Is a good thing...
They were just happy to see people going to see a movie...
Yeah!
Exactly!
So I...
I actually get it...
And...
I mean...
I'm...
Not part of the solution...
I don't go to the movies either...
But I also don't go outside...
Very...
Really either...
So...
I finished their video halfway through...
To pay respects...
To them leaving the cinema early...
So true...
So before we leave...
I want to gather some extra supplies...
So maybe we can...
Get some extra points...
You know...
And other...
Things unlocked...
Maybe...
Uh...
Am I reading any new books lately?
You know, Brian?
I really haven't...
I haven't had much time...
I recently watched it...
And our theater wasn't super crazy...
But a small child did shout out...
Chicken Jockey and Crafting Table...
Alongside Mr. Black...
See?
That's so cute though...
No!
I think that's okay...
That feels wholesome...
At least...
I'm afraid to go though...
Because I don't want to get...
I don't want to get like...
Some...
Some soda thrown at me...
Or something like that...
So I'm afraid...
What else?
Oh, let's try...
I don't see any creatures here...
So maybe we can get some mushroom...
Come on, mushroom...
Trying to get a mushroom...
There was like...
One of the achievements...
Was a mushroom thingy...
Went to the theater to see...
Gundam...
So the solution...
At least for me...
Is to have more giant robot movies...
And how many people...
Were in there with you...
Fairly...
How many people...
Also went to go see the movie...
What is it pronounced?
Dang it...
Still no...
Q...
G...
Quacks...
G-Quacks...
Anyone see...
The Miku movie...
Oh, the...
Project Sekai movie...
Miku movie...
I haven't...
I've...
I literally have not gone to...
The movie theater to see anything...
You're watching it today...
The Miku movie...
Minto movie...
No...
You know...
Back in the past...
I used to say...
I used to be really adamant...
I used to be like...
I...
If I ever had a movie made about me...
I would want Jack Black...
To play me...
You know...
I would want him...
To...
Be the role of Mint Phantom...
And now I think I might...
I...
I don't...
Um...
Wow, there's so many spitters here...
I...
It's not that I don't want...
Him to do it anymore...
It's just that...
I just...
I wonder if it would be...
If it would be like...
Oh...
Jack Black is in the movie...
But the Minecraft movie is not a flop...
I was gonna say...
Jack Black is in the movie...
It's a flop...
But...
I don't know...
Weird Al as Dokki Bird...
This is kind of insane...
Wait...
I want Weird Al...
I want Weird Al in the movie...
Sweet...
Finished Blueprints because of your streams...
And that genuinely...
Felt like three to four books...
In a single video game...
How long did it take here...
To finish...
I want to get the...
Hold on...
I don't want that guy to get me...
But I want to get the Fireflies...
Trying to get more stuff so that...
Oh my gosh...
Nevermind...
I can't see anything...
It's so dark...
And it's so...
I don't know if these give us anything...
Guess not...
You are not soon...
Jack Black Minto...
Good morning Minto...
He would say that in the movie...
Okay...
I guess we can just leave this world...
40 days...
If Gilbert Gottfried was still alive...
He'd be the perfect...
Jokey...
Why do you...
Why?
Because he played a bird...
Once...
He played one bird...
And...
That...
That makes him qualify...
Zendaya as...
That I can see...
Jack Black saying...
Oishiku naire moimoi...
Cute needs to happen...
Like I still love Jack Black...
But...
My only thing is...
I feel like...
With the Minecraft movie...
How do I say this?
Arigato...
Thank you...
Oh my gosh...
That was so loud...
Two months ago...
I got this VTuber themed...
Green Thanksgiving candle...
In a mug...
After two years of...
Transit from Japan...
It's cute...
And it smells so good...
I had to get it shipped to me...
A couple times...
But it was worth it...
Say...
Oh my gosh...
I haven't seen you ever...
Thank you...
So much...
Oh there's...
Places crawling with skellies...
But I want the mushroom...
I don't really have like...
A shield...
And my health is not...
Good enough...
But the sun is starting to come out...
What was I saying though?
Oh...
It's not that I...
I feel...
I fear...
Jack Black is just playing himself...
In most of these movies now...
You know what I mean?
So would he embody...
Mint Fanta?
Or would he just be...
Jack Black...
Wearing Mint Fanta...
Outfit...
You know what I mean?
I've seen the Mint Fanta movie...
Starring Jack Black...
Weird...
I know I've read that as...
Weird I...
Like AI...
And Jason Momoa...
No...
Maybe we can get this one...
Doesn't seem like there's anything here...
Um...
Yeah, I just fear...
That it would be...
Jack Black...
Wearing...
My outfit...
And not actually being like...
I am...
I...
I am Minto...
You know?
So...
Hmm...
It's just one of those...
One of those things...
Hello from Philippines...
Hello!
Thank you!
My pick for Mint Phantom is Willem Dafoe...
Is that the guy with the...
Like...
The...
The guy that...
That...
He...
Yes, okay...
I'm just making sure...
Now...
Why?
Green Goblin...
Wait, that's right!
I gotta get dirt, don't I?
Wait, let's make...
Oh!
Look!
We got a swamp biome!
Nice!
When did I get that?
Who knows?
Um...
Let's make a...
Oh!
Let's make...
Let's get some more dirt...
Let's make a...
Shovel...
I'm just gonna take apart this whole place...
Some upgrades do actually screw you over...
I got one last time...
Who did that to me?
Hehehe...
My biggest breakthrough...
That got me to finish this...
The game was...
Observations in the chapel room...
Oh!
My observations!
That turned out to be an end game clue!
Here's $10 for helping me finish the game!
I...
Oops, sorry my bun...
I have astute observations!
No!
Wow!
Thank you!
David Hayter's gotta make a cameo!
I would want him to write the...
Screenplay maybe?
He's really good at that...
David Hayter is really good at like...
Writing...
Ah!
Hot dog indeed!
I think I get a lot of points if I...
Get dirt...
That's why I'm collecting dirt...
And...
I think I'm done!
Oh!
There's dirt down there!
And mushroom!
And more dirt!
I think I just drop dirt...
Like I'm...
Stinky...
Nasty...
Is this modded?
No!
This is...
Uh...
April Fools...
That...
Um...
An official April Fools...
Version of the game...
I suppose you would call it...
Haha...
I hope I like...
Kind of expand on it though...
It's kind of awesome...
How much are the...
Mushrooms worth anyway?
69!
Yeah...
I hope you guys are doing...
Well...
Today...
I hope you guys are doing well...
Um...
It's...
I had a really busy day yesterday...
Real real busy...
I've been real busy you guys...
I've been...
I've been cooking...
Did you get a lot of work done?
Yeah...
What the hell?
Oh there he is!
Hello!
Uh...
I did get a lot of work done...
This today...
Actually there's more...
That I gotta get done today...
As well...
But uh...
Oop!
That just...
See?
I'm just throwing dirt...
Still no...
Special mushroom it seems...
Disappointing...
I don't even know if this is how I'm supposed to get a special mushroom...
Unless I...
Maybe I have to like...
Pick up an actual mushroom...
For anyone...
Wondering...
There's like a...
Some...
Some sort of achievement...
With the mushrooms...
Where you can unlock more world...
Different...
Types of worlds...
Um...
But uh...
I guess I can just say...
Cause it won't be for a long time...
But um...
Uh...
So...
And it's...
Whatever...
You guys will forget...
Probably...
Eventually...
So basically...
I am...
Working on...
Well...
I got a new...
3D model...
And...
I'm working on...
Having a...
3D model...
Concert...
Debut!
To...
Which is so exciting...
Um...
It won't have a lot of guests...
But a few...
And...
Um...
I...
Actually...
Have...
Like...
Someone helped me...
Get...
Like...
A really...
Really cool...
Um...
Like...
3D studio...
It's...
I...
I don't know if they've ever worked with VTubers before...
But I'm super duper excited to work with them...
And...
Um...
That's kinda what...
A lot of like...
The...
What's it called?
The budget is going to...
Yay!
We got swamp biome!
So...
I...
Like I said...
It won't be for...
Quite a while from now...
Um...
But that's also why I'm going to Japan...
Uh...
Next month...
So...
Part of the reason...
And...
Um...
Proud of you, dummy...
Yeah, that's true...
You guys don't forget...
I'll mention something...
And then you'll like...
Ask about it...
Months later...
Was this the six times your expected budget thing?
Yes...
But...
It's because I really wanted it to look...
Like...
So professional...
Like I...
Have very high standards...
And so I was like...
I...
And I know...
Oh my gosh...
I can't wait till...
When I can tell you guys...
Because then you'll be like...
You'll be like...
Holy moly!
Like...
That's why it looked so good!
So I'm gonna...
Obviously I can't tell you now...
But...
Hmm...
You'll be like...
That's why it looked so good!
Wowee!
So...
It's...
You know...
Gonna be all really...
Really...
Professionally done...
Hehehe...
And so I was...
I'm excited about it...
And I'm nervous about it...
I'm nervous if like...
The payoff will be...
Worth the amount...
I suppose...
But it's also...
Not always like a...
Uh...
Like I'm not gonna make my money back...
I know that for sure...
But...
It's not...
It's not about that...
It's also like...
Just for me too...
You know...
Like I wanna be able to...
I went with the more expensive option...
Because I was like...
I wanted to look good for you guys...
And I wanted to look good for me as well...
So...
And it will be free...
On my channel...
So...
Yeah...
So you don't have to worry...
Swamp I am!
Let's go!
Wait...
I see swamp is kinda strange...
No?
Let's get...
Wait...
So I think slimes are already in there...
Um...
Skellies...
Spiders...
What else do we want in here?
Um...
Amplified world...
Floating island...
Dark forest...
Jungle...
Mud has more value than dirt...
It does!
Cows for food...
So true...
Let's get some food in there...
Yeah...
You're so right...
Um...
And we got slimes...
We have no other like...
Hostile mobs...
Which is kinda nice...
The fact that you're doing it at all is...
Awesome and worth celebrating...
Thank you!
Pre-order from my concert ticket...
Let's do...
I kinda like to make this...
Oh actually...
Let's do Acacia...
Because like...
Savannah...
Because it's like...
Weird...
I wanna like a weird combination...
Something you don't usually get...
You know?
That's what's really fun about this...
Game mode...
When is the concert?
I can't say...
But it won't be for several months...
Yeah...
Ducky...
Thank you so much for the fun...
Thank you!
Oh my gosh...
It's so...
I forgot we're in the slippery...
Wait...
I did...
Why do we have dark wood too?
Why is it...
Always raining?
One ticket please!
Thank you!
Oh I also got an upgrade...
What are we at now?
30!
Thank you Cryos...
Thank you!
I don't want you guys to feel like...
You have to...
Donate or anything though...
I...
But of course...
It's also not the only thing...
I'm working on...
But...
I figured...
You know...
Um...
I actually...
Have a meeting about it tonight...
So I'm excited...
I'm meeting with like the...
I'm meeting the 3D team...
And talking with them about...
Everything that we can do!
Hehehe...
So...
And I got some other...
Really exciting news last night!
You guys...
Exciting things are happening...
Which is exciting!
Ticket and merch bundle!
Wait...
That's not how you get the merch though!
Stop!
Look at there's lots of mushrooms here...
Um...
Is there any food around?
Hehehe...
Any food...
For me...
To eat?
Where's my cows?
Hehehe...
Where are my cows at?
Everything's coming up Minto...
I'm trying!
Hehehe...
I want you guys to be like...
Yeah...
Being mint fan is...
Really awesome!
Hehehe...
Wasn't there one that we...
Start with like a...
Pickaxe, no?
Maybe it's...
Which one?
Oh, this one maybe...
Starting pickaxe!
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
Okay...
Dig...
Oh!
I think I can get this!
Yeah...
Wow...
Diamond even...
Okay...
Oh!
Wow, they already gave it to me!
This is what I was trying to get!
Oh my gosh, no way!
This...
We got the mushrooms!
Oh, it has been...
Yippee!
Haha!
Triple the defense and dance budget!
Hehehe!
I've been like...
Creating my set lists...
And...
Making...
I think it's pretty cool!
Yuck!
I think it's pretty good so far!
So...
In my opinion...
I don't know...
I'm extremely proud of the...
Vehicle!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
But yeah!
That's what I was working on yesterday!
And...
Other stuff...
Oh my gosh!
Whoa, we're so fast!
Whoa!
Ouch!
Where are my cows?
Oh, there they are.
Oh, he's probably a dummy.
Well, I don't know.
I want you to be like, wow.
She's doing things.
I don't know.
Okay.
Wait, I need a stick.
Actually, we'll do an axe.
Come here, food.
Nice.
Thank you.
What's that over there?
Is that a goat?
That's a goat.
Okay.
Um, how much did he give me?
Nine pieces from two cows!
Chunky fellas.
Wow, real hefty.
I want to stay in this biome because it's not raining here.
Why is it getting so dark?
Wait, is it getting... Is it...
What are you guys?
The crackling.
No way!
That's the... The pale oak... Wait.
Oh my gosh.
There's a thing right there.
The exit's right there, but the... The creaking!
They're not the... What did I say?
More cow.
Hold on.
We're going to cook our meat in a second.
Yeah.
Oops.
Please.
Hold on.
Holy cow.
What did I get?
Gave me so much stuff.
And we... Oh my gosh!
Wait.
We got the mushrooms and the mushroom field biome.
That's exactly the two things I was trying to get before.
Food.
Wow.
They give you so much food.
Oh.
Oops.
Sorry.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Big beef.
Yeah.
Holy food!
Wow.
Why do they give so much?
They're generous.
I gotta go get some...
Stone over here.
So we can make a...
Uh...
Furnish?
Hopefully there's some more...
Doesn't seem to be any more coal.
That's so sad.
This is such a bizarre...
Biome makeup.
Wondering what's your most anticipated figure.
Mine's Chobits...
Oh!
I...
Wait.
The Chobits one that's like her on the...
The telephone pole, right?
I did see that.
I did see that one.
My most anticipated.
Every moment with Minto makes me feel that I'm in mint condition.
And you've made our world much brighter.
I'm proud to be your fan.
Tome.
Thanks, Syntax.
I don't know.
I have...
I would have to see...
I would have to see what...
Figures I have pre-ordered right now.
Because I recently...
I recently...
Had one that I really wanted.
It was a YouTube camp one.
But it was so expensive.
And...
I was like...
In...
Holy moly.
I was like in an effort to save money.
I...
I let it...
I let it just roll over.
I didn't...
I didn't get it.
So I was like...
I...
I need to save money.
So...
Oh...
Oh, that scared me.
Okay.
Oh, I wanted to see if we could get some like new...
Something here.
You know.
Maybe not.
I have...
I honestly don't have much room left in my...
In my figure shelf anyway.
So...
What I've been doing actually...
Is I've been...
Taking an extra suitcase...
With me to Japan.
And filling it up with figures.
And then selling them at Mandarake.
I've been selling them.
I've been...
I've been selling them and...
Oh, nice.
Oh, like...
Figures and other like...
Weeb merch that I don't really...
You know.
So I...
Well...
And I don't...
You know, honestly...
Like I don't make a ton of money back from it.
Because, you know...
Figures...
The original figures were so expensive, obviously.
But...
It's not like a...
You know...
It's...
It's good like spending money.
You know?
It's actually...
Good like a little bit of a...
Like, yeah.
I...
I get a little bit of...
Like...
I can...
I'll be like...
Oh, I'll go buy like a new outfit with this.
You know?
What kind of deal?
Hey, party people!
And I'm cleaning up.
And I also feel much better.
Because it's like I'm...
I'm cleaning my...
My place.
And also...
Not like...
Like...
What else?
There's a bunch of stuff that I'm like...
You know?
Maybe someone...
Will see it.
And be like...
Oh my gosh!
I've been looking for this figure forever!
But...
Maybe like an average person...
Would not...
Care.
You know what I mean?
Like...
It might be like a little bit more niche of a figure...
Or something like that.
I don't know...
What mobs are gonna spawn tonight.
So I'm kinda scared.
Haha.
But we have that guy up there.
We gotta go too.
I almost missed it!
Blackstone bio!
Nice!
I almost missed it.
Nice.
Thanks for the fun streaming though.
It's my birthday!
Neptune!
Happy birthday!
I'm hungover.
Haha.
Sounds like you already had a good...
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you...
Happy birthday dear Neptune...
Woo!
Happy birthday!
Okay, maybe nothing is gonna spawn.
Oh, I'm literally... Ouch!
I'm throwing rocks, I'm throwing rocks.
I mean, dirt, not rocks.
My bad.
Do you think we can go up in there, you guys?
All I see are goats.
No creepers, no skellies, no spiders, no... Wait, didn't this have slimes, no?
I know it had slimes.
Okay, let's make... I wish I could find iron.
Because I want to make a sword, but we got a pickaxe, at least.
Chicken jockey.
I wonder how we can get chicken jockey.
Gonna get a happy birthday for my 30th.
Argentine, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Argentine.
I hope I'm saying your name right.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
All right, let's create.
You know what?
If I die... Wait, no, I don't want to die.
Because I got the mooshrooms.
I got...
The exit's right there!
We would just... leave, right?
I'm scared though.
Creaking is scary.
The creaking is so freaky.
Let's see.
What's a good way to get up there?
It's also weird walking around at night and...
Not feeling like... have to look over your shoulder.
I guess if we go up here, we will though.
I'm being brave.
Is that a skelly?
No, that's a go.
Almost had me there.
Oh no!
It's on fire!
Wait!
Wow, look at all the flowers.
Are they gonna burn?
Nice.
Any... any creaking?
Oh, holy moly.
Any creaking?
Start cutting some pale wood.
Maybe we'll get a pale wood biome.
That would be so scary though.
That would be the freakiest... biome to get.
A whole thing of... pale wood biome.
I might cry.
Creaking creaks!
Where is he?
Where is he though?
I think he might be able to one hit me, no?
You saw it?
No you didn't.
Oh, dang it.
Um...
And I didn't bring another axe.
But, we have wood.
I can make another crafting table.
That's how you play the game.
You make crafting tables and...
You... you know...
That's how you play the game.
Um...
I'm scared of him!
I'm scared...
Oh, I got a sapling.
Uh...
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Creaking creaks!
Where?
Where are you mister?
Where are you?
He's creaking?
He's doing his thing.
Can you hear it?
I'm too much of a baby.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm too much of a baby to go in there.
I'm so scared!
The guy has so much HP too!
He sounds so close!
I don't think he's behind me.
I actually have no idea.
He definitely sounds in front of me.
The forest is on fire.
How about yours?
That's the way I like it.
I'm never gonna burn.
Hey now, you're a rockstar!
Get to get in my...
Go play!
Hey now, you're an all-star!
Let me get paid!
All the glitters and gold!
All the shooting stars!
Break the mold!
Any of them?
None of them?
Oh, gosh.
It scared me.
None of them seem like...
Seeds...
For new worlds, unfortunately.
I could keep going inside, but I hear him!
You guys, I hear him!
Sorry!
He's really freaking me out!
He sounds so stinking close!
I
actually don't know where he is.
He might be below, actually.
I wonder...
If he's below...
I think he's watching me.
If I go back to camp, will he follow?
You know?
If I go back...
Will he follow me?
I said look by...
Oh!
It's almost daytime!
He's gonna die soon!
For everybody telling me to trap him and put a name tag on him, I don't think you understand what we're playing.
Do you want him to follow you, though?
No.
Oh!
Oh, I'm so strong!
I'm the strong...
Wow!
I'm the strongest!
To ever do it!
Yeah!
I wonder how much you get for these.
How much experience?
0.6.
Well, that was her first...
One punch made!
Aw, dang it.
I'm trying to see if we can get...
Actually, would I even want a biome, though?
Of all...
Would I even want this biome?
Like, yes and no.
You know?
Yes and no.
Maybe I'm like, he's behind...
Or he's below me.
I'm totally safe.
This is a big biome, though.
It's a big area.
Ouch!
I'm strong.
I'm not strong.
I'm not strong at all.
Oh, let's put...
Turn these into sticks.
It's my birthday child!
Happy birthday!
I'm really happy I get to watch your stream while I'm working.
Can I be greedy and ask for a mother-based birthday song?
Of course!
It's my favorite.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
With salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Woo!
Happy birthday joy!
Look at this, too!
We also get so much more...
Oh, I just realized I could make a stone axe.
Heh heh.
We also get so much more, like, uh...
Experience, because...
Pale biome is spooky...
And rare.
So...
I'm gonna keep going until we can maybe...
Maybe until it's nighttime again.
But I wanna try...
Either nighttime, or...
We get...
Um...
The seed...
To be able to...
Do our own...
Pale biomes, you know?
I don't know which...
If it's the trees, if it's the...
The moss...
I don't know.
A shiny biome, yeah.
Might as well break the soil, too.
Yeah!
Like, I don't know...
Ooh!
Can you imagine if that was it?
And it just...
Drifted away?
What's that?
Oh, nothing.
We will take apart this entire biome...
Mold by mold!
What was that?
Hunter.
Come
on!
Where's my seed?
Even though I don't wanna come back here.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
So spooky.
Why would they...
They...
Are not beating the...
Minecraft as a horror game allocations.
With...
With creating this, you know?
Oh my gosh, you guys!
I really...
Want to play...
The new...
Oblivion!
Oh my god!
My entire TikTok is all just oblivion clips now.
Cause I keep liking every single one that I see.
Oh, I wanna play it so bad.
I wanted to play the original one.
Um...
Cause of all the funniness that I see about it.
But I wonder if...
But I'm also kinda like, maybe I...
It would be such a long saga.
I don't know...
Quite yet...
How I wanna go about it.
Hmm...
Let's do oblivion!
It would be really long.
I have so many other games I need to play too.
So...
I wanna play...
But oh my gosh...
They really were just like...
We're gonna keep the charm of the original.
And then...
Meant it.
Cause I was kinda nervous.
I was just like...
Actually, I was like thinking about it.
I was like...
I don't know if I would wanna play the remake.
I think I wanna stick with the original.
Because...
I think...
I was like...
I don't know if they're fixing the jank.
And also...
Like...
You know, I like the jank of the...
Of the old graphics as well, you know?
But...
But at the same time...
But now I'm seeing it.
And I'm like...
Wait, it seems so...
Like the original.
Like they didn't change anything.
It just upgraded graphics.
But...
I...
It's impossible to fix jank.
It makes me so happy.
I know.
And I've never played it before.
So it would be a...
First time ever experience.
Which is always exciting for me.
Besides like the few clips that I've seen.
Of like...
The...
NPCs...
NPC-ing.
Oh!
Another one.
Wait, where'd that go?
Wait, where'd my...
Oh!
It's in the trees.
My resin.
I wanna get it but 60 game backlog.
Yeah...
But I wanna play it.
I want to play.
So maybe...
We'll...
We'll do that.
Sometime.
I don't know.
Who knows?
Maybe I won't be able to give in.
Or...
I won't be able to resist.
And I'll give in.
And I'll...
I'll play it next week.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Today is not my birthday.
However, it is the 282nd un-birthday.
I'll very merry and birthday to you.
To you.
Okay.
We have so much pale wood.
At least I'm gonna get experience from it.
It's really good playing it right now.
It feels just like the original with better graphics and a few...
Oh!
There are some quality of life improvements.
That's always a plus too.
Good to know.
Let's steal some of the flowers.
I'm thinking maybe...
The...
Like the...
The droppings from the tree is what might give us the...
The seed.
Hopefully.
Either that, maybe the flowers.
I don't know.
They fixed the screwy leveling system.
Oh, I didn't even see...
I don't even...
Like I said, I've never played it.
I didn't even know that was an issue.
So maybe then it would be better to play though.
What is it?
A remaster?
I'm scared.
The creaking is going to come out any second.
Wait, I kind of killed him though, didn't I?
Actually.
Now that I think about it.
I broke his little heart.
But there might be more.
So yeah.
Oblivion's been on my mind.
Like all today.
All this morning.
I was just...
I was just watching TikToks and laughing to them.
I'm just like...
Look at that NPC.
Being dumb.
Yeah.
It's a good thing though that I took yesterday off.
Cause I was not feeling well at all.
Oh my gosh.
I was feeling so, so bad.
So...
Honestly...
It's good.
That I took it off.
But...
Today I'm feeling a little okay.
I might actually start doing two days off a week.
For the unforeseeable future.
Because...
I told you guys...
This is also why I wanted to tell you about the concert.
Because you guys know that I've been having issues with like my voice and everything.
And I'm like...
I need to sound good for a concert.
So...
Might be having more...
Days off.
Just for that.
That's why I was like...
I don't want you guys to think that I'm getting lazy.
Because honestly, I was like...
Yesterday I was like...
What if I stream?
What if I just...
I don't know.
I guess...
Even though I was working the whole day.
It's not that...
Sometimes I...
When I take a day off.
Sometimes I don't work.
And I get bored.
And I'm like...
What if I just stream?
Because I'm bored.
But yesterday I was working.
Pretty much that whole day.
And even still I was just like...
I want to stream.
It's called a weekend, Minto.
Then I'll be like...
Oh...
I'm leaving.
To me...
I...
Never think of it like that.
Because I just feel...
I feel like...
What I get to do is so easy and so fun.
That it's not like anything...
For me to...
Just...
Do it all the time.
Why no rest?
Wait to bye.
Why?
I don't know.
Okay.
We can leave now.
I think I got enough stuff.
Not even the resin.
I guess it's...
Because a full stack of wood is 1.28.
And then...
Minto streams everyday.
Sometimes twice a day.
Minto, am I lazy?
I don't want you to think I'm...
Sorry.
I don't want you to think I'm lazy.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Sorry.
I don't want you to think I'm lazy.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Wow.
We got the Moonshrooms.
Oh, nice.
Forty-five.
We're killin' it.
Give it to buy.
Never think.
Valid.
Moonshrooms.
And, oh, Axolotl.
Wait, I want to go to the...
Arigato, arigato.
How do I go to the Moonshroom world?
I'll see if we have spiders here.
Oh!
I messed up.
No!
Even Minecraft says to do what your rest is.
Why is it always raining?
This is calming to you.
Calming where?
Oh, look.
We got a diorite base.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go... Oh, I thought that was lava for a second.
Let's go find...
Um, our exit.
Especially because this is not what I wanted to create.
Eh.
Will the spiders get me?
It's not nighttime, but it's dark.
Mate, you scared me.
I'm sorry!
Look how many spiders there are, actually.
At the first fanart, I post and your tag is cursed.
But the brain worms made me do it.
What are you talking about?
Are the spiders gonna get me?
I can't tell.
Friend or foe.
There's so many of them.
I retweeted it.
Wait, which one was it?
Oh!
Yeah, I remember seeing that.
Yeah.
I remember seeing that.
Yes, I do.
I don't know.
What is wrong with that game, though?
Like, what's...
What's the issue with it?
I don't know anything about it.
Cannibalism!
Don't find me wasting this furry milestone chat.
Oh...
So it's, like, pretty freaky.
Interesting.
She didn't know.
I didn't know!
Yeah, I didn't know.
Interesting.
Is it, like...
But I see so many people playing it.
Is it because it's, like, really...
Like, a good story?
Or is it just because it's freaky?
Like, is it, like, the shock factor, you know?
Sounds right up your alley.
Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
Okay, at least we got a food source here.
No!
You're a foe!
You're foe!
Dang it.
They're foe in the rain.
Okay.
Good to know.
Oh!
Whoa!
I'm crazy.
Crazy crap!
Uh-oh.
I think I can mine this without...
It's a good game.
Is it?
Don't die with your levels.
Oh, you're so right.
Let's, uh...
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's upgrade.
What the?
I got foxes!
Let's...
Let's get our level.
Let's get, um...
Ah!
Maybe this.
Shield bash.
And then also maybe the sword.
I can at least get this one, alright?
Safety hole.
Oh!
Woo!
This guy sounds right next to me.
Uh...
Wait, I'm trapped.
Wait.
There it is.
I think they're right above me.
Did I get a shield too?
I did.
Let's go.
Okay.
We are less afraid now.
Everybody.
We are less afraid.
Wait, wait.
Ouch!
Oh, why isn't it working?
Why doesn't it...
Why doesn't it shield?
Wait!
What the hell is it doing?
What is that?
The shield isn't shielding!
Wait, what the...
How did I get that?
What?
Oh gosh.
Guys, we can't...
We can't die here.
We have too much good stuff.
Well, good is little, you know.
Did I just see a sniffer in the water?
As...
What the hell?
Don't you dare?
Deep dark, baby.
Am I ready for the deep dark?
Absolutely not.
Will I...
Oh my gosh, I almost jumped down, but I would have jumped into the...
I would have jumped into the lava!
Wait, can I jump down?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I cannot.
Why?
Um, let's see.
Okay, hold on.
I wish I could use my shield now that I have it.
Okay.
I think from...
Oh gosh.
Uh, okay, hold on.
I have an idea.
Watch my genius.
I did it.
Is this an outside?
Whoa!
How?
Oh?
It's an outside...
Uh...
That!
Lush cave!
Yeah, but it's not a cave at all!
I hate destroying it, but I want to...
Maybe get lush caves as a biome, you know?
Wow!
I want to get lush caves as a biome, maybe.
Maybe if I destroy this...
What the...
Why isn't some of this destroying?
Wait, uh...
I messed up.
There we go.
Neat.
This is neato!
I've never seen one so, like...
So...
Out in the open.
You know, like, sometimes you can find the caves that...
Like...
Go down really deep.
And so you'll see, like, a lush cave from the outside.
But, like, this is just...
It just feels like it's a...
Lush cave...
Out...
Outdoors.
It's really weird.
Meatou, meatou, meatou.
That's my name, baby.
Don't wear it out.
I have to find the exit, though.
Still.
We even got the berries.
Oh...
How do I get the berries?
And it's starting to get dark.
Oh no!
I see sniffers.
There's sniffers everywhere!
Look at all of them.
Let's make a boat...
And travel around.
Let's make a boat, baby!
A boat, a boat, a boat.
I can't believe we got the deep dark biome, though.
That's terrifying.
I don't know if I like that.
I don't know if I...
Really want that.
I think.
I'm also gonna make some...
Let's throw some things away.
Like you.
And we're gonna make some sticks.
And...
We're gonna make some torches.
Whoa.
I'm just gonna light up this area real quick.
Okay.
I just always feel safer with them, you know?
What's that?
Oh.
Alright.
Our boat.
Our food.
Evil and suffering biome.
I know.
Scary.
Minecraft is a horror game.
I want the...
I want these, though.
Oh.
Oh, look.
There's so many.
There's more.
Okay.
Turn around.
Cause it's scary.
Woo!
Look at this!
Okay.
What we're gonna do is take all of it.
Maybe something will.
Maybe?
No?
Okay.
Nothing.
Am I throwing moss now instead of dirt?
That seems to be...
Yeah!
I am.
That seems to be the case.
I love these cozy little cave areas.
Right?
They're so cute.
Look in here.
Oh, yep.
I'm throwing moss.
Okay.
We got axolotls doing their things below us.
But we gotta find the exit.
I don't remember.
It was...
What was it again?
To make the eye of...
No.
It was like the eye of end or something.
I know it was copper.
Which we've seen.
Actually, now I think about it.
Copper and something else.
Copper and iron.
Oh, I see.
We don't have any iron.
Well, that's okay.
We can also just explore.
Comfie Minto craft stream.
Hi, Eric!
Yosoro!
Also, welcome to membership.
Eye of exit.
Yeah.
How we get out of here.
We get our sniffers...
Everywhere.
Why does this look so ominous?
There's like nothing beyond.
I look so spooky.
Oh, there it goes.
Love exploring with Minto.
Thanks!
I also like just the exploring part.
I guess that's why this version kind of tickles my fancy.
Because...
It's less about the building.
Which I don't mind the building, obviously.
Wow!
Look at the...
Rush!
Wow!
But I also just really like the exploring parts of Minecraft.
And here we...
It feels like we're always going to find something...
Interesting and bizarre.
Because all the worlds are strange.
Stay away.
But finding the exit can be a little...
Tough.
Like, what if I went the wrong way?
Oh wait!
There's multiple exits though, no?
I remember.
I remember somebody telling me that.
Stay away from me, beast!
Ugh!
Finally!
Oh my gosh!
Whoa!
Look at the...
The
waterfalls in there.
Crazy.
Yay!
We got a spitter.
Spitter trophy.
Very nice.
Thank you!
If you manage to find an Amethyst Geode, it's basically free EXP.
Amethyst blocks are worth quite a lot and easy to mine.
Oh yeah!
I have to really dig in there though, huh?
I really have to dig...
To find something like that.
I don't need...
Do they?
Whoa!
These formations are crazy!
I...
I wonder though, does it...
Like, is it...
Have to be...
In...
Written into the world?
You know?
Diggy diggy ho!
You're...
Love your Half-Life stream.
Sorry about not being on topic.
Can't really watch...
Streams now.
But watching those vlogs...
Really lifted my mood for those...
For these two weeks!
Oh!
Sergey!
Thank you!
I'm happy about that.
No worries.
I'm streaming.
I think it's on topic.
What's a topic anyway, huh?
Gosh.
They're so violent behind me.
Let's not go towards the spiders.
Let's go this way.
Let's just keep going.
Let's just keep going and going.
I mean, I was sending my first ever super job to ask for the birthday song.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Oh!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, I missed it, S-Dog.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear S-Dog.
Make shizzle.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
What a name.
Wowie.
Cool.
Let's see.
I still wonder, now that it's not raining.
Once the sun comes up, will the spiders still be hostile?
Because if not, this is like easy mode.
You know?
I wonder if it just passed.
I don't know.
Crow, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
What's today?
Wednesday?
Yeah, it's Wednesday.
I keep getting my...
I'm all so...
I'm so brain fogged.
I keep getting all my days wrong.
Oh!
Never mind.
He's faux.
He's just blind and didn't notice me at first.
But it's not...
Okay, now it's like fully day, right?
It wasn't fully day before.
Right?
Now it's fully day.
Hold on.
We gotta go find another spider to test this out with.
Willem Dafoe.
Oh!
I see it!
I see the exit!
What?
Is he...
The foe?
William!
Why are all the sniffers in the water?
I don't understand why they get trapped like this.
Okay, let's just run.
It's over there.
Petition to get mint a calendar.
I don't know what's wrong.
I think it's...
I've been a little brain foggy.
Lately.
I mean, you know, as a ghost, it's like...
Do days really matter?
Time.
What is time, anyway?
Instead of brain, there is fog.
Where did...
Where did it go?
Oh, over there.
Aha!
Wow!
Finally, one that's not underwater.
Nice.
But I didn't get to test my spider theory!
We gotta go find another spider first.
There are gonna be arounds.
Maybe not.
Or despawn, because it's daytime.
Just kidding.
Okay, never mind.
They're all gone.
We can leave.
Sink or swim, mint phantom.
He has every turn game.
What exactly is Tom?
Even though he is an octopus.
He's dead without him.
I wonder when we'll get our next key.
And we got a new spider.
I think that's... I think the spider is actually... I don't think I got a spider trophy before.
Let's check.
Look at all this.
Look at all these stinking... I have so many of the stupid silverfish though.
Time is a tool you can put on your wall or wear it on your wrist.
The past is far behind us.
The future doesn't exist.
I hope we can fart the fog away.
What is happening?
The maybe not so deep and also maybe not entirely dark.
Wait, what else do we have in here?
Spiders.
Is this going to be terrifying?
Maybe.
Let's get some... Oh, I can't do... Oh, they have cows already.
Let's do...
Ocelots, obviously.
And a piggies.
What else do we have?
Swamp biome.
This is going to be horrifying.
Maybe.
Here we go.
Depends
on if you find him.
Oh, wow.
How awkward.
So far?
Wow.
Look at all the... Wow.
Look at this... Wait, are we floating island?
Whoa.
This is so weird.
Where are all the trees?
All the way over here.
I need wood.
Wait, here's some.
Where's the...
Where's the deep dark?
I'm scared.
So much lush biome.
Maybe that's a good thing.
Until I hear like a...
You know, sound.
The...
How do you make that now?
It's like a...
You know what I'm talking about?
It's weird on the surface.
So weird.
Will the warden appear on the surface?
It'll be too bright for him.
No.
Right?
See, like...
I'm used to seeing sometimes lush caves like this.
If like there's a big old crevice.
But...
Anything else is...
This is really...
It's so flat.
It's...
Shut up.
Is that a family of ocelots?
Look at all of them.
You guys.
Why are there so many cats?
Why are there so...
Little babies.
There's so many ocelots.
Why are there so many of them?
Oh my gosh.
I've never seen so many ocelots.
I don't think I've ever seen a baby ocelot.
Where?
No.
Where is he?
I pretend I do not see.
Nothing happened just then.
Anyway.
Alright.
We got some wood.
Let's uh...
Let's also upgrade.
I only got 14 levels.
That's not so good.
Before we like...
We killed it.
We got so many.
I can't even shield bash.
Um...
Chopper.
Bring a snack with you.
We could start getting...
Maybe an archer would be good.
Get more experience upgrades.
Where are those at?
Crafting table.
Smelt.
Need for speed.
Dirt?
Where's the dirt?
Sorry.
I thought I heard something.
Bottom of the first tab.
The jump?
One.
Ah!
Get more experience.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's do this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Cool, cool, cool.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I didn't realize that that's what those were.
I'm also gonna get swift sneaking because we're about to uh...
You know...
We're about...
I think actually even last time I was just like...
I don't need this unless we have the deep dark, baby.
Which um...
Welcome.
I guess.
Where is it?
Where's the deep dark?
I already see the exit.
No way.
Easiest biome ever.
I like the fireflies.
Underground?
Let's see if we can find it.
Because there's not really a way to get underground, as you can see.
We're floating in the sky.
Underground doesn't really exist.
So...
Wish I could get some coal, though.
So I could cook my food and run.
Do I have any stone even?
Nothing.
I don't even see...
I see a bunch of spiders down there.
Wow, that's kind of pretty.
But I don't see where deep dark even would be at.
You know?
I don't think it exists.
Do a flip.
If I went down there...
Baby.
Little babies.
Oh my gosh.
Why are there so many of them in one place?
I don't think the deep dark exists, you guys.
Oh, we can eat the berries.
This is good, actually.
We can eat the berries.
Give me.
Here's our sustenance.
Instead of eating raw meat, I guess.
Ocelot trophy.
How do I...
Wait, what do you mean, ocelot trophy?
Oh, by killing them?
No, shut up.
That's horrible.
That's horrifying.
How dare you even suggest...
Such a heinous act.
By kissing them?
Hello, little Axelot.
Oh, you're so cute.
Wonder if I can get a trophy for him.
Come here.
Wait, what was that?
Wait, what?
I got something.
Wait, what...
What did I...
What was the spell that I just cast?
Guys, we got guardians.
That seems kind of terrifying as well.
I don't think the deep...
Did I...
I did add it.
No.
Like, I did add it to the world.
I don't just...
Don't think it exists.
Huh.
How disappointing.
It's rare-ish.
Oh.
On top of your screen?
Oh, yeah.
It is there.
Huh.
Maybe because it's like...
Rare, usually.
It's rare to find it in here as well.
You know.
It's not as...
Vast as I thought it would be.
Whoa.
This is so bizarre.
We can try again, though.
Maybe...
Without...
The Lush Games have overpowered everything.
I need to write.
I'm good.
I'm gonna try murdering more innocent creatures.
So that maybe we can unlock other things.
So if I murder this guy...
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't get anything.
Except...
No, I got something.
I got guilt.
I've unlocked guilt.
Oh.
What?
Oh, see?
Wednesday frogs?
It is Wednesday, my dudes.
Wait.
Actually...
How do they know it's Wednesday?
How do they know?
Okay.
Oh, God.
I...
I need to close my eyes for this one.
Oh, no.
I'm running out of...
Stamina.
I'm so sorry.
I'm gonna get mad cow disease.
You guys, we have to do it.
We have to see if we get anything.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Okay.
You're going way further than I...
Want to go.
I can't tell if that's deep dark or not.
Let's just leave this one.
This world's strange, but I think we've kind of gotten everything.
Boss, you just murdered a child.
Oh, my God.
The whole family.
Stop running with me.
Wait.
Where'd the exit go?
Oh.
I lost the exit.
Yellow closet time, paradox.
It was like over here somewhere.
It was...
Ah!
Right here.
We can leave.
Fine.
Right.
We don't get a lot.
But we get two more new things, which is kind of fun.
And
I might be able to...
Unlock...
A little bit more.
That was your favorite world so far?
Nice.
Oh!
Igloo in space!
Uh-oh.
It's a boss world.
You guys!
Uh-oh.
Ha-ha-ha!
What does this mean?
Well, we have a shield.
Ruining the game.
A fox.
Huh?
How am I supposed to...
do anything?
There's snowmen over there!
Wait, there's snowmen everywhere!
What?
And polar bears!
Wait.
I hope you're doing well today.
Thank you for the stream.
I saw a cute video with several clips of you singing...
Minky, Minky, Minky.
Ha-ha!
Yeah, I do say that sometimes.
Check the basement.
Oh, is there one?
Oh!
Wait!
What did I just unlock?
Cave world?
Is that not what we're doing now?
Oh, there's no guy.
Oh!
Look at that!
Huge!
Oh, wait.
I got a...
potion of weakness.
A splash potion of weakness.
How do I...
Oh my god!
Stop screaming!
You're scaring me!
How do I...
How do I traverse?
Sleep to make it day?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna show you right now, buddy.
No sleep for you!
Not today!
Wait, what's this, uh...
What does this mean?
Oh, igloo in space.
Okay.
Um...
Gotta build a bridge, I guess.
That's what I'm thinking.
But I can't collect snow.
Oh, wait.
We can collect stone.
Let's take apart this little world.
I'm glad that snow doesn't cave in, you know?
Like, how...
Um...
But how do I get back...
I guess...
We'll just use some of the stone to get back out.
But yeah, I'm glad it doesn't cave in like how sand does.
Does she know how to make a cobblestone generator?
Oh!
That's probably why they gave me this...
The lava!
Uh...
I'll be honest.
I don't know how to make it.
Like...
I don't know.
Actually.
Oh.
Oopsie.
Tuh!
It's just like...
Hold
on.
Let me get out of here first.
Make some stairs.
Okay.
And then I like waterlog the stairs or something...
Something...
I don't...
Okay.
Hold on.
Stairs.
First crafting table.
Oh.
Ah.
I have.
Stairs.
Just don't allow the water to flow into the source lava.
It's like...
Hold on.
I'm going to look it up.
What's the word?
Cobblestone farm.
But like super easy.
Wait.
These ones don't show stairs.
Cobblestone generator.
Farm gets me.
Generator, not farm.
Okay.
Generator.
Yeah.
I saw someone also say that the lava might melt the ice.
Which could potentially hurt our farm.
So let's stick down to the stone.
Or we could do it down here actually.
Now I think about it.
Yeah.
We can just do it here.
There's snow.
Ah!
What?
Why?
Dang it.
Nasty creature.
Okay.
Luckily we have more water if I do mess up.
You know?
What I will do instead is I will...
Create something like here in the corner.
You know?
So...
Like we'll just...
Like this.
Like so, right?
So that we don't have to worry about any...
Any...
Issue with snow.
Okay.
But I just don't know...
Hold on.
I'm gonna watch a YouTube video.
How to make a cobblestone generator in Minecraft.
You need a water bucket, bucket of lava.
One, two, three, four.
Four line.
Is that how many I did?
One, two, three, four.
Oh, I did an extra one.
That's fine.
Then...
We'll do...
From the third block on the line...
Dig one more block down.
Well, this still worked.
Is this still...
A valid farm, I wonder.
No!
Oh, wait.
What we can do is this...
Watch my genius.
What did I need stairs for?
What?
The physics didn't change.
Okay.
Cool.
Place the water bucket on the last block on the right.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Lava.
Place the lava on the far left block.
Once the lava...
It'll create cobblestone.
And that's it?
That's it?
Stairs are to prevent the water from flowing.
But I think that's what this hole is supposed to do, no?
Yeah, like that.
And then...
If I dig here...
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh.
Uh...
Wait.
How do I collect it?
Um.
Oh.
Oh!
I got that one!
Okay, I am...
I am getting them!
Oh.
It's like a one in...
Something chance.
Yeah!
Look, look, look, look, look!
Four...
Five...
We missed that one.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
It's down here.
Slow, but it works.
You know what?
This is so good, actually.
Because...
Um...
We can always come back here, you know?
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna leave a torch here.
So that we know this is the home base of our cobblestone generator.
If we...
Have to come back!
How do we get out of here?
Holy cow.
I don't even...
Do you think those guys are friends?
First off, let's travel.
This feels like...
This feels like, uh...
Being in a...
What's it called?
Um...
The one block dimension, you know?
Or...
No, not one block.
Um...
The, uh...
After you beat the ender dragon.
No, not sky block.
I've never done that.
I know what you...
I can infer what it means from the name.
Use slabs.
You're right!
Slab.
We've doubled our property value.
In the end...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys think these are friends?
They're not...
They can't be foes.
They're...
They're snowmen.
They love me.
Hello!
Hello, friends.
What do you got here?
Don't push me.
I thought we were friends.
I didn't realize they were so...
Fragile.
Uh...
I see it!
You see...
You guys see it?
All the way up there?
That's the exit.
Oh my gosh, I see it.
It's very...
It's very small.
Where my crosshairs are pointing is right there.
Oh.
Gosh.
I need a lot more cobblestone.
Oh my god.
What I also want to do is I also want to grab some more water.
Never mind.
Please!
Okay, never mind.
I was going to say I want to grab some more water so that...
Um...
So that...
Uh...
I could...
You know, just in case I start...
I actually fall or something.
Oh!
I thought I went too fast.
Please.
This is like the slowest process ever.
I could take the water and lava with you.
True.
Oh, well, that's the...
Well, yeah.
I guess we could build it with the...
With the cobblestone.
Because my only thing is the...
Is the ice.
You know?
Oh, come on.
Please.
Eh!
Mind the block here?
Aha.
I was scared about getting...
Lava'd.
But it doesn't seem to be the case.
Okay.
Oh.
Heard about the big event coming up at some point.
Oh, the joy!
Thank you!
Still at work when it was brought up.
So proud and excited.
I'd also take a break sometimes.
Wait, wait.
Thank you!
Come on!
Um.
Nah.
We'll get there.
Eventually.
Someday.
Let's put some of this stuff away.
The stuff that...
I was like...
Oh, I need this.
But I don't actually need it.
Oh!
No!
I don't have anything...
That I can cook my potatoes!
Oh, man.
Very slowly...
It doesn't help that it's like one...
It's like...
50-50 chance.
Take care of your presence is comforting.
I'm not...
Guys...
I think we need to talk about this.
I'm not supposed to be comforting.
I'm supposed to be a very spooky, scary ghost.
I am.
Some random person.
Thank you so much for the talk.
Thank you!
I'm supposed to be like a really terrifying...
Horrifying...
Like...
Nightmare fuel...
Paralysis...
Demon...
Type of ghost.
This is...
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
This is...
Inefficient!
Oh...
I...
The tree and the charcoal...
True.
But there's no tree on my little island.
Unfortunately.
Wait!
Is there some in here?
No!
But I will take this.
Ha ha ha ha!
So we don't have to use any of our resources.
Eek a ghost!
Yes!
That is an appropriate reaction.
That's an appropriate reaction.
It's scary how cute you are.
If I use a shovel for the snow...
Do I get to keep it?
Or does it have to have a...
What's the word?
But also, I can't...
Oh wait!
I have a shovel.
I was gonna say.
I can't make a shovel.
Does it have a...
No.
Let's see.
Oh wait!
But I can...
I can make it myself.
Can't I?
I can make the blocks with...
Oh gosh!
I gotta be careful.
Holy cow!
Oh!
Wait!
Up!
Snowy biome!
I can make my own blocks.
Snow.
Yeah!
Thank you.
For reminding me about this.
Gosh, it's been so long since I've played Minecraft.
That it's like I...
It's...
I do feel like you have to...
Use every single Minecraft knowledge you've ever known to...
Play this properly.
Sorry.
Sorry, work is busy.
No!
Please do take breaks.
I'm okay!
Thank you though.
Thank you for the pink targo.
What if I get rid of all of the...
Of the snow?
Snow.
This is good though.
Snowblocks.
We're making a lot of them.
In a short amount of time.
So.
I don't want to fall into the void.
All right.
There's some more.
Okay.
Snow.
You're absurd.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Wait, I can craft them in my inventory?
I can?
I can.
Oh.
Wow.
Snow.
Okay.
All right.
We're getting somewhere now, baby.
Okay.
We're soon going to take off on our journey.
I promise.
Honestly, the snow blocks might be better than the cobblestone.
Might be a better strat than the cobblestone.
But I am...
I think I might take our search on the road.
Or like our setup on the road.
I'm still going to leave this so that we know where we began.
Our humble beginnings.
I'm going to take our setup on the road.
So give me...
Our buckets.
Oh!
I had more!
Smoo.
Okay.
Where'd our buckets go?
Oh, here they are.
I'm silly.
Okay.
Smoo.
Every floating island gives us more snow.
Oh, that's what I'm saying.
We're going to take...
Oh, we'll take it.
Because it might be hard to find wood sometimes.
And that should be it.
Guys, this is a...
This is a harrowing experience.
It was like...
It was over that way.
I could go to that tree.
I think about it.
But I'm already here.
So...
Oh, there's a tree right in front of me.
We're fine.
I wonder if it's going to stay night.
What's the shriek?
Oh, that scared me.
It's, uh...
It's, um...
The fox down there.
He keeps yelling.
Hello, Mr. Bear.
Don't mind me.
You have no children.
I'm going to block you with me.
Okay.
Hello, sir.
Kind of wanting to kill the bear.
See if we can get anything from him.
You know?
Oh my gosh.
It's so dark.
I can't see anything.
Oh, I want to maybe kill the bear.
Maybe I would like to...
Destroy the bear.
Did he hurt me?
Maybe I deserve that.
Where'd my...
Where'd my wood go?
Okay.
I use...
I can use the logs, no?
To...
Instead...
Uh...
Let's do this.
You here.
And then the log.
And then the potato.
Nice.
You see it up there, guys?
You can see it.
You can just barely see it.
Okay.
Why are we destroying bears?
Well, you know...
They could have added valuable resource.
They could have given me a seed.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm surprised I'm not throwing any...
What's it called yet?
I haven't been throwing any sorts of blocks.
You know?
Not that I can tell.
Oh no, it's going down fast.
It's not gonna be able to cook all my...
Potato!
Oh no!
Let's also make some more snow.
Nice.
And I'm gonna keep all of our...
Things of like, you know...
I'm gonna get rid of the carpet.
Goodbye.
Goodbye carpet.
So these are our seeds.
Ah.
Okay.
Well, we got...
We got seven.
That's not so bad.
Could have been worse.
All right.
I'll take you.
And um...
Up we go, baby!
White!
There's some wood.
You son of a gun.
Okay, anyway.
We'll just take it for now.
Okay.
Oh, hold on.
My chat is frozen.
One moment, please.
One moment.
Okay, dokey.
Nice.
Heard about the Gamersupps NSFW.
It's not NSFW!
It's not!
It's...
What?
Who say...
Who's calling it NSFW?
Huh?
What?
How?
Where?
NSFW, how?
Who?
I mean, maybe...
NSFW...
And yeah, you shouldn't wear it to work.
But like...
I think that's most anime clothes.
No.
You can... you can... you can wear it to any anime convention.
It's not... it's not even remotely... it's not even remotely...
more slightly dangerous than... than the stinking Ahegao shirts that exist out there that people wear on the regular.
But also... if you're so like...
If you're... uh-oh.
Wait, oh, he doesn't have a baby.
If you're like... I don't know, Minto.
Um, just wear a jacket with it.
Easy peasy.
Hello, polar bear.
Oh my god.
Okay, he's over there.
He's not bothering anybody.
Wear a jacket!
It's... the... the... the... the... freakier side is on the back.
So, you just gotta hide it and you'll be okay.
I'll probably wear it to any future con I visit.
Yeah!
I'd wear it either way.
See?
It's not so bad.
It's... it's not so bad.
But I'll be honest though.
When I... you know...
When I got the design, I didn't... think that they were gonna make it into a t-shirt.
So... I wasn't like a...
I... um...
I didn't really think about... the... it would... how it would look on a t-shirt.
The freakier side is on the back.
We moan about you for ages.
That's a con home shirt for me.
It's really soft though.
That's the thing.
It really is nice to wear at home.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
It did break the ice.
Oh god.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Now you and...
Finish making my potatoes, please.
Oh man.
No!
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
It's melting the ice a little bit, but that's okay.
Everything is okay.
It's not that spicy.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Sayonara.
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine if I was on top of that?
Alright.
Let's make some more snow.
Very good.
You guys see it up there?
We gotta get even higher.
Can we get much higher?
Just because you get in trouble for wearing it at work, please.
Yeah!
Alright.
Soon.
I'm just trying to get up as high as I can.
And then maybe...
Maybe once we get to more...
Now that I'm out of potatoes...
We can use the wood for...
This instead.
You know?
For...
Yeah.
For that.
So we can...
Get even higher.
I'm so happy to talk to you at Sakura-gan.
I'll be wearing my mint hoppy to a big music festival next month to represent my Oshi.
Let's go!
Thanks, Aardvark!
Alright.
Okay!
You guys can see it.
Let's make our way over that direction.
Look at our humble beginnings.
So long ago.
I think we can get up there.
Hello!
Excuse me!
I would like to...
Um...
Inquire about your supplies.
What do you have to offer here?
Your...
Your body!
Thank you.
Oh, dang it.
I lost it.
Ha ha ha!
Ah!
That's not what I meant to do either.
Sorry.
Um...
Thank you.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Alright.
We need that wood.
Mmm...
Mr. Fox.
Don't do anything drastic.
And...
There will be no issues.
They were just chilling.
Yeah, but I need their...
Body.
I need their...
For the snow.
The snow is rich in material.
Ahem.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I can't see anything.
I can't...
There we go.
Okay.
Is Mint also getting her own gamers up flavor?
I think you can only get a flavor...
If you sell enough cups.
Ha ha ha.
If you sell enough merchandise...
I believe that's how you get the flavor.
Ha ha ha.
So...
As a whisper, I'll probably wear any Minto merch to support my Kavi Yoshi.
Especially a cute Minky t-shirt.
For...
I understand though that it could be...
You know...
Way too spicy for some people.
Um...
I think the...
I think if anything...
The...
The cup itself could be okay.
You know?
But I understand if some people don't want to wear something like that.
So, because of that...
I have been like brainstorming some other...
Fun...
Um...
T-shirt ideas.
Like there's one...
That I really want to do.
Uh...
Which is like...
How do I say?
It's my style...
But you wouldn't think it is.
Is...
I guess how I would say.
It's kind of hard to describe.
We could start taking the...
Hold on.
This...
The...
Where'd it go?
Did you...
Did you eat it?
Where is the...
What?
Oh, the dirt!
There we go.
And we can start planting trees on it too.
Just realized.
Yeah.
Like IRL style.
It's more of like...
I don't want to say it so much without giving it away.
But it's more of like a cooler style.
It's like...
You know...
I love Moe.
And I love cute.
But...
Obviously I want to create different styles that...
Lots of different people.
Oh my god.
I'm...
I'm messing up.
I'm ruining it.
That a lot of different people could...
Enjoy.
So...
As you said, it's safe for work.
I'll be wearing it to my government job.
Yeah!
You show them.
You tell them.
You'll be like...
This is what...
This is what we should be investing in.
I just realized there was another tree down there.
Oops.
Hello, hello...
Thank you.
Sorry.
Hello.
Thank you.
I must murder.
I'm sorry.
I must.
For the snow.
Just tell them this is my Oshin no explanation.
They'll get it.
They'll understand.
They'll be like...
This is what the kids are into.
This is what we must invest in for the future.
I guess maybe I should leave one alive.
And we can just create infinite snow with the guy.
It's so close, you guys.
Oh my gosh, it's so close.
We're so close.
It's right there.
Let's go to this island right here.
Okay, just kidding.
Snow.
We're running out of...
We're running...
We're pretty running low on supplies though.
Wow, it's the sun.
Hello.
Oh.
Who was that?
That wasn't me.
You guys saw that though, right?
Oh wait.
I'm stupid.
There we go.
Don't look down too much.
I'm getting dizzy.
I have to.
I'm sorry.
I must.
I wish it wasn't so dark though.
It's so hard to see.
I'm
hearing something about Minto clothing merch.
Maybe.
Who's spilling the beans?
I get...
I don't know what made me think of this.
I get such random emails.
Like spam emails.
That are just like...
Oh.
Hi.
Hello fellow...
Um.
Like recently I've been getting ones that are like...
Hello.
Fellow diver.
Would you like to...
We would like to sponsor your channel...
For diving gear.
And I'm like...
What are we...
What?
I'm a diver now.
Um.
It's pretty funny.
But I always know when...
Like sometimes...
Spam emails can be pretty convincing.
You know?
Oh my gosh.
Please don't leave.
Don't leave.
Stay with me.
Okay.
Um...
Some of them can be pretty convincing.
But I always know...
If it's a spam email...
And if it's trying to be convincing...
Because...
What it does...
What they do...
Is they'll be like...
Hello.
Um...
I'm really into...
Hello Myth Phantom.
I'm really into your content.
Like I've been watching your videos.
And...
When you said weh...
It really moved me.
And when you said...
Pop pop pop pop...
I was just rolling on the floor laughing.
Hahaha.
Because I have videos...
Because I have the videos that are just like...
VTuber says pop pop pop pop...
And they always...
Reference that one...
For some reason.
Hahaha.
They're always just like...
Yeah.
We loved when you said...
Pop pop pop pop.
Hahaha.
I don't understand.
I guess because they don't look at...
Live streams...
They look at like...
My actual uploaded videos.
Which I don't have...
Very many of at all.
The receptionist said...
This one government building...
I used to go to...
Covered the entire reception desk...
In toy shoes.
Oh.
Neat.
When you said weh...
It really moved me.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
So you know...
My pop pop pop pop video...
Is pop pop poppin' off baby.
Hahaha.
That's so close.
Let's...
Let's go out.
Some.
Did you guys watch way three?
I sure hope you did.
Nice.
There's another...
Uh...
Another...
Tree.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Of like words.
Words escape me.
Excuse me.
We're so...
Close.
We feel...
I feel so close.
Ah.
Wisps.
How many have you watched...
Way three multiple times...
In the past day?
Yeah.
How many?
My wallpaper.
How did you make your wallpaper...
From way three?
Four times.
Yes.
Hahaha.
Kanye.
Makes for the super jet.
50 times?
Okay.
Very nice.
Did it move you?
Pop...
Maybe I should make a sequel to Pop Pop Pop Pop.
So that they have more...
Material that the spam emails can use.
Hahaha.
Maybe I need to upload more videos.
I'm going to have one this week to upload.
Snow.
I think I'm going to get rid of...
Get rid of...
Oh!
I just realized I have a cooked salmon.
Let's eat that.
I didn't realize I had cooked food.
Nice.
All right.
Let's get rid of...
String.
And the stick.
Okay.
Oh!
I just realized I have a lot more slabs.
Nice.
Okay.
Good.
You guys, we're going to make it.
We're going to make it!
Boss, the Minto socks to make the ultimate Minto travel fit.
Think of the socks and sandals.
Also, Wisp plush win.
Um...
Well, I did have sandals with the...
With the...
With the podcast.
So I wasn't...
Thinking about...
Making any more anytime soon.
I was like...
I...
You know...
That was only last year.
So it feels fairly recent, you know?
But...
Maybe...
Maybe more.
Minto official socks.
Actually, someone gifted me some...
What's the word?
Some...
Some, like, Wisp socks.
And I don't wear them out, obviously.
But I do...
Wear them at home.
I even wore them yesterday.
You guys are on my mind...
And on my feet.
All right.
Create more snow for me, please.
Yeah, you're doing such a good job.
You're doing great, sweetie.
No!
Maybe I can trap them.
Okay.
Now, how do I collect the snow?
No!
I didn't trap them good enough.
I messed up.
Oh!
Please don't push me.
Please!
I know I murdered your brethren, but...
How do we want to do this, guys?
How would you do it?
Oh...
That was a good amount of snow, though.
Would you say you step on us when you wear the Wisp socks?
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
Actually...
You stay, like...
Right where you are.
No,
no.
Please.
Please come inwards a little bit.
Inwards.
In...
Don't look at me.
Please, I'm not gonna kill you!
I promise.
No.
These guys are ruining my vibes.
I like how they give you diamond gear, because they're just like...
You...
You would have to really mess up.
To...
Um...
Not be able to make it.
You know?
I feel like I could.
I feel like we can at this point.
No?
I don't.
I feel like we can make it.
Let's try it.
I think you can just go for it.
I think so, too.
Okay, what I'm gonna do is go up here.
So we're a little bit higher.
And then we're gonna use the slabs to go...
Long distance.
But what if...
I don't have enough to get to the top?
What if...
All right, all right, all right, all right.
We...
I have 32 and 20...
Oh, I have 64.
Oh, we're so good.
Never mind.
We're fine.
We'll make it.
Oh, we are so good.
Oh!
We...
We've got this.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy.
Wait.
32, 64.
Let's use this instead.
Easy peasy.
Oh!
Give me my key!
Yeah!
Yahoo!
Where's my key?
I didn't get one.
No way!
Oh!
I did get one!
Yes!
Let's go put our world away.
It's a spooky looking key.
All right.
Shimmering key.
We have...
Opened the door.
This one.
And it led to other doors.
Like this one and this one!
Something wrong.
What do you mean something wrong?
What about down here?
Oh.
Hall?
Door.
Door you just clicked.
It's showing me that it like...
Opens other room...
Oh my god.
That scared me so bad.
I thought I was about to die, you guys.
I thought I was about to die for real!
Something wrong.
Wait.
So this is just going to open...
Something wrong here too.
This is just going to open another room with doors.
See?
Wall, door.
There's just more rooms!
What about...
I mean there's other...
These doors...
Oh.
I forgot something.
There's this one over here as well.
But it's also just going to...
I missed the sock discussion.
Did Mito socks get announced?
No!
I was saying...
Why?
Do you guys want socks that badly?
You guys want socks that badly?
Key has a specific room.
Opens useless room.
Ahhhh...
No!
So this is not...
A useless...
This is like a useless room.
Whoa!
Interesting.
Let me out, please.
Mintoes.
Alright.
What we wanted to do...
I don't want zombies, but I want it.
Wow, look at all this stuff we want.
TNT.
Shut up.
Let's make like the most dangerous, scary world.
Wait, we are in the deep dark.
Okay, we got skellies, we've got zombies, we've got guardians.
Let's make the most horrifying, terrible thing ever.
I need... we got sheep.
Wait, actually...
Wait, didn't I unlock a mooshroom biome?
I guess we can't use it.
That sucks.
Oh wait, there it is.
This way.
But before I do this, let's use our levels.
Fourteen.
Nice.
If I lose six levels...
That's fine, maybe.
Or we'll do that one.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's go.
It probably wouldn't fit me.
What are you saying?
You got big old feet, yeah?
Once again, we are in...
We are in Lush Biome Takeover.
Lush Biome?
Why is the Lush Biome Takeover so much?
It's like in a...
It was the...
That was the exit!
The exit was right next to me!
No!
Wait, can I go back in?
Revisiting an old one that was lost.
Look!
It's right next to me!
I just turned the wrong way!
Aw, man.
That's so sad.
Oh, another one.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
I thought it was a creeper at first.
How am I activating these traps?
I don't understand.
Are they...
Am I like clicking on something?
Wait, what's that?
Oh no, that's just some seeds.
Random TNT spawning.
That's so messed up.
Okay, let's try.
Let's do Mu.
Mu.
Deep Dark.
I want to find the Deep Dark.
Oh, we got Guardians.
Okay.
Mushrooms.
What else we have?
Andesite Savannah.
This is...
Freaky.
We would've gotten 1.5 XP.
Because the exit was right next to us.
It's so messed up.
We would've had 1.5 XP.
It is once again!
Oh my god.
We need to go.
We need to leave.
Please.
Give me out.
Just run!
I got another key.
Junction.
That was terrifying.
Yeah.
I didn't think the Guardians would be in all the water.
I didn't think it would be in everywhere.
No.
Junction.
What was another sad face that we got?
Oh!
Wait, we can get stuff in here even?
We can start collecting...
What?
What am I supposed to do with this stuff?
This place is wacky.
I know!
What?
I think I saw another...
Yeah, there's a door here too.
Did
I get all my XP?
Why are we allowed...
How can we farm?
I wonder.
Hold on.
I wanna see with the old worlds.
So, okay.
Wait, there was two of them right next to each other.
Three!
Wow, we've never been so lucky before, you guys.
Look how many exits there are.
Just within like a...
I was wondering if you like can go into creative mode.
Nah.
But...
Clearly not.
Clearly we would just die.
There's another one over there too!
Ouch.
Interesting.
Crazy spawn.
Yeah.
We're gonna die.
Ouch.
Okay.
I think you get put in adventure mode.
That's terrible.
Someone just has spawned with a ton of exits.
Crazy.
Crazy, crazy, crazy.
Look at all the things we still haven't...
Actually!
The things that we haven't undiscovered yet.
Eat some bamboo.
Maybe not me.
Um...
Win a mind that never sees the light of day.
Wait, I did that though!
The one that was...
Wow!
Five times!
Probably dried out among fossils.
Buy from a villager?
We haven't even gotten villagers.
But there's actually not so much...
Like it used to be really, really long.
Of things that we haven't discovered yet.
But now it's...
It's...
Very...
Gradually getting smaller and smaller.
They really cooked with this update.
They did!
Waterworld plus fish out of water is a broken combo.
So...
Let's see...
We haven't done a cave exit, but...
I don't think I can...
Yeah...
Oh wait!
The next one is a cave exit!
Oh no!
Well, we'll just go into a cave.
Very fun.
And let's do...
Deep dark.
We got chickens for food.
Let's do...
Mushroom islands, except not only islands.
I wanna still try and find a mushroom biome.
I think that would be fun.
Deep dark mushroom...
Cave world.
Cave mushroom biome?
Seems crazy, no?
Oh, the Wednesday!
Wait...
I forgot about the Wednesday frogs.
For some reason I have so much sugar can.
Are we in a cave?
Uh...
Oh...
Oh!
There's so many Zombos!
Uh...
I think we are...
In a...
Cave...
Ish?
What the hell?
Is that water down there?
I see the exit!
What is this?
Hello, Zombo!
I still can't use my shield properly...
Which...
Oh, there's another!
Oh wow, there's a bunch of exits again!
Let's go!
Where did you come from?
We once again...
Got a really lucky spawn.
Which one do we wanna go to?
I'm trying to...
I want to explore but...
I guess we can...
This is so strange...
It's like...
I can't tell if we're in a cave or not...
Because it's so bright...
You know?
It's not dark at all...
There's so many next to each other...
There's one over...
Oh!
Hello!
Oh my gosh!
They're all gonna become drowned!
Oops!
There goes my...
Wait, but it's so far down...
The...
Huh...
This is so strange!
It's raining zombies!
There's so many zombies here!
Tweet tweet!
Is this lava?
What the?
The...
The lava is waterlogged?
Whoa!
There we go, baby!
Now we'll never...
Water in the fire!
Why?
How?
Water in the fire...
Why?
I wonder if you could like...
Fall out of the map...
In this one, you know?
Wait, I got...
Magma cubes!
I must have gotten that...
For mining the magma!
That's awesome!
The magma...
Why did I say it like that?
Please...
Grab it, thank you!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
I wonder...
Wait...
Can I mine the obsidian?
Let's try it...
The magma...
Get magma...
Oh, I do need diamond, you're right...
I'm sorry, I forgot...
Completely forgot...
This is...
I don't...
I don't know why we're in a cave world...
That is also like so...
Filled with water...
That's what's confusing me if...
Oh...
No, no, no, no, no, no...
Glow squids!
This is so weird...
This is so weird!
Sorry, I know I keep saying how weird it is...
But it's actually just so weird!
Maybe glow squids gives us something too...
Like, look at this!
I've never seen...
It's very cool and very weird...
Will we reach the bottom?
Go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go...
Nice!
Holy cow...
Almost didn't make that...
It's about that diving sponsorship...
Please!
I did get something new...
You know what?
I'm just gonna go to this one over here...
There...
This exit...
We'll just stick around over here...
You know?
I wish I could get...
Ouchy, ouchy...
Some armor...
Oh, yeah...
Nope!
Oh, gosh...
Oh...
My Mogba!
That was close...
Saw the designs for your Gamersubs merch...
I think it's all super cute...
I love the Metal Gear reference on the cup and shirt...
I also love the cute skateboarding Minto design...
Thank you, Dreadnought!
Thank you!
Glad you like it!
Oh, this is lava!
Oh my God, it's so weird!
Okay...
Um...
It's waterlogged...
Magma...
Pew!
Man, what else can we get?
Hold on, let me look at my inventory...
I don't...
I feel like I have nothing...
You know?
I feel like I...
Haven't grabbed anything...
We at least got a new...
Ingredient...
Grass...
Got some flesh...
It's hard to...
Go around in this one though...
I fear...
Oh gosh...
Wait, are we gonna make it?
Oh God...
No, no, no, no...
There we go...
Okay, we got some...
Some air...
Back...
Oh my gosh...
The ceiling is so high...
Too much water...
And not enough water...
It's like...
Way too much water...
I didn't expect we would be getting such a watery...
Area...
You know?
It's...
Like...
Why so much water?
Water...
Why...
So much water?
This would be great...
If I had like a...
Potion...
For water breathing...
Oh, there's another one up there...
Even...
Wow...
Two out of ten...
Too much water...
Spoken...
I was...
I was literally just thinking that...
But I wanna explore some more...
Oh...
Okay...
Excuse me...
Because I wanna see more of the cave...
It's just so bright in here...
It's...
Magumai's Walrus Kaiju...
That was in Toho's 1962 film...
Gorath...
Wow...
I learned...
I did not know that...
Maguma...
There's that one over here...
This one doesn't look so deep...
I guess let's...
Let's just go...
Exploring by water is too slow...
And I don't think I can get back up there...
So...
We'll just go home...
Let's just leave...
Wait, is that a geode?
Do you see that?
It's like perfectly round...
You don't think that's a geode, right?
It looks...
It looks weird though, no?
Look, there's even beyond...
There's even deeper...
Giant egg...
That has to be a geode...
Right?
It's so deep down though...
Hold on...
Maybe we can find a...
A bubble...
To pull us down...
Under...
Has to be a geode...
I think so...
Hold on...
Where's the...
I can't tell what's lava...
And what's...
Magma...
There we go...
Weeeee...
Woohoo...
Uh oh...
I'm losing...
There we go...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
You guys...
Jackpot!
My eyes did not deceive me!
Nice...
I'm gonna put...
Mine right there...
Uh...
Go...
Okay...
Awesome...
Ouch!
What's...
What's killing me?!
Why?!
I was on top of my thing, no?
Wait, why is it...
Why is it not generating?
My magma's broken...
Yeah, what happened to it?
Why no bubbles?
Let's see now...
Okay, I think we're...
I think we're okay now...
Let's check...
Nope...
Not this one...
Um...
Hold on...
This one's okay...
But this one is not okay...
Hmm...
Needs a source block...
What does that mean?
Ouch!
I'm gonna die...
Warden boss fight!
Since when?
Still no good...
I wish I had...
A food...
I think we can go in here now though...
Yes!
Okay...
Awesome...
There's nothing in here...
Nice!
You know what?
We're not coming back here...
We're just taking everything...
Yes!
If I eat the rotten meat...
I think it'll be okay...
You think it...
Do you think that's better than nothing?
We're taking everything, baby...
You've done it before...
To regain health...
Okay, yeah...
I think...
I think you're right...
Oh, you're still right!
Yeah...
Yes!
Do these also...
Count for anything?
Or...
Ding, ding, dong, ding, ding!
Wow!
That's a lot...
Of...
XP, baby!
And look...
The warden boss fight!
That sounds really horrifying...
And terrifying...
And...
I don't like anything...
I wanna do!
Getting back up is gonna be a doozy...
But...
I believe in us...
I believe in us, everybody...
I believe...
I feel...
It feels so wrong...
Breaking the ones with the X's on it...
Hahaha...
It feels so wrong...
What does a warden boss fight even entail?
You have to...
So, defeat him?
Doesn't that guy have like a million HP?
Lots of death.
Yeah, I'd imagine so.
A full stack is 12!
Damn.
I think that's the most we've gotten.
I think that's the most HP or XP we've gotten.
Okay.
I want to keep going, but...
How do I get the top ones?
I guess we can just use...
Like this.
The calcite.
How much is the calcite worth?
There's an exit nearby.
Yeah, yeah.
So, we just gotta get to it.
Okay, since we're already at the bottom...
It shouldn't be too difficult.
Hopefully.
I say.
I pray.
Okay.
I don't want any of it...
Despawning.
Come here.
Okay.
Let's go to the side.
Alright.
I'm gonna say enough for a cute ghost attacks.
Thank you!
Oh, no!
My...
My pickaxe is almost...
You guys, my pickaxe is almost up!
I might have just enough to finish the cave.
Ouch.
I shouldn't have done that.
Ouchie, ouch.
But I didn't want to use it on the calcite.
Someone said save for magma blocks.
And I do have one...
Well, this is...
I don't know.
Let me see how close we are to...
Ouch.
Oh, gosh.
To the exit.
I do not see...
The exit.
But there's a lot of magma blocks around.
I thought we were close, no?
Maybe it's this way.
There it is!
Okay.
I think we can make it.
I think we'll be okay.
So we can get more.
We'll do...
We'll just go until it breaks.
We'll go until it breaks, baby.
Famous last word.
Stop!
Oh, there it is.
There it goes.
Alright!
Time to go home!
Alright.
We can make this.
Oh, yeah.
I'm just being extra cautious.
And look at that!
Yippee!
Logan!
Welcome to the Vapashop.
Thank you!
That was so...
So satisfying.
Wow!
Our most lucrative world yet!
All the way to level 80!
Yeah, baby!
Wow!
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow!
Let's use our...
Let's use our upgrades.
And then we're gonna do...
The Warden.
And then I'll call it.
Let's see.
What should we upgrade, you guys?
Actually, I'm going to...
Go to the bathroom real quick.
While we decide...
What to do.
Hold on.
Remind me to harvest a geode next time I go mining.
Thanks, Vinto.
Yeah!
Thank you!
I'll be right back.
I looked so pensive.
I looked so...
I don't know why.
I am...
Guys, you probably can't tell.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Hold on.
Let me see.
If I like zoom in.
See how my bangs part?
Right...
Right there on the...
On the...
Your right side.
So...
My bangs used to be like completely straight across.
And...
Recently, I have gotten like a cowlick.
I don't know why.
And it's so frustrating because all I want is straight across bangs.
But...
Every time...
I got...
I got a little cowlick.
And I...
Usually, it can be even worse.
It can be even worse.
But I like...
I force it into submission.
A hogevirus real.
It's actually...
I have one.
And I like always fussing with it.
A hogevirus.
Can you please zoom in on it more?
What?
Is this your...
Kink?
Right there.
Right...
On the...
On the side.
That's a big one.
No!
It always bothers me.
Alright, guys.
For...
The...
Mr. Man's.
The warden.
We could be faster.
We could sneak faster.
This is possibly even faster than running.
Swift to sneak.
No way.
Vector Tom!
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you!
Armor.
Yeah, armor would be great.
Decked out.
Oh, gosh.
It's so expensive.
I kinda want...
What is this one?
A natural evolution of a shield.
What is this?
For anyone who has played this before.
It's a mace?
Is that a new thing in Minecraft?
Is that new?
Did they recently add this?
Oh, it's a new weapon.
Really?
I didn't even know that they added that.
Wow.
It's in the trial chambers.
Wow!
It came with the trial chambers.
Deals more damage if you fall further before hitting.
What?
It's a rare reward.
Wow!
I thought it was something for this.
Okay.
Maybe we get the shiny sword.
And we get...
Hold on.
Okay, I can't get the shiny sword anymore.
We could get the archer.
I just don't understand why the shield doesn't work.
Oops.
Spent it all on armor.
Oops!
You can one-shot the warden?
How?
Spellbook?
What is that?
I'm curious.
Wait, it also says touch the campfire after unlocking a spellbook.
What does that mean?
Hmm...
Let's get the archer one.
Okay.
Now I have nothing.
Which is great.
Because if I die, I lose nothing.
So...
Warden.
Wait, what if he's not in the deep dark?
What if he's...
Mushroom Fields Bio?
What if he's just...
Doing his thing?
What if he's just out and about?
Warden.
We're not gonna do the explosive traps.
Warden wards off the competition.
Do you have lava?
I could get lava.
Let's try the squishy...
Squishy magma cubes.
I kind of want to see...
Let's just make something really random and weird.
Okay!
Why do I hear people?
What the hell?
What is...
What is going on here?
What is this?
I finally...
We got our mushroom biome.
I hear the warden.
Is he down there?
Is he inside there?
That's your boss fight.
What?
No way.
Um...
Hold on.
I need to get over there?
Oh!
I got a bow, but no arrows.
Kinda creepy with the villagers.
I don't understand what's going on.
Is this enough?
I don't know.
Whatever.
I just want to get over there.
Maybe it's not enough.
Dang it.
There!
I see a magma cube down there!
This is so weird!
But she's so kawaii.
Oh no!
This is so weird.
They're watching like it's a cage fight.
Is that actually what's going on here?
Wait!
The exit's right there, you guys!
Why are we getting these exits like this recently?
The exit's right there.
I could leave.
But I don't get my warden boss fight.
Let's make it nice and easy.
For us to...
Get over here.
They're not going to push me in, are they?
What is this?
This is so weird!
What?
Oh, he's just right there.
Is he like sleeping or...
There's like a...
What is happening?
What
is happening?
if I go onto this...
Here.
Is he a...
Is he snoring?
I think he's snoring.
Why is he a warden?
Aw, man!
In the end, I didn't even lose to the...
A stick at warden!
Oh!
Get your groove on.
What happens if you die in a boss battle?
What happens?
Wait, it's actual warden time?
Real?
You die for real.
I'm already dead.
Because I have nothing to lose!
Okay, since I died so quickly in that one, we'll do this, maybe.
Unless I die.
And then we'll, you know.
Why did I get that wild blow?
Oh, it's happening again!
What is going on?
Why do they keep floating in the sky?
Why does this keep happening?
Hold on, I'm trying to find...
Wait, is this an actual village?
Yes, there's a village!
This is my first time seeing a village in these places.
I hear them just...
They're coming everywhere.
I've never seen a village.
Oh, it's gone quiet.
I wonder when they will go at...
Start the fight.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Wait, what do you...
What?
Who's...
Are those my thoughts?
Who's thinking?
Huh?
I'm a sentient?
I'm not trying to ignore it.
I just want to see the village.
There's two of them.
I just wanted to see the village.
Ouch.
I've never...
It was an achievement to trade with a villager.
And maybe they have things that I can...
You know...
Like a bunch of bread.
Wait.
Find some arrows.
I'm trying to find anything.
Trying to get anything.
Okay.
We got a horse.
Can I ride that horse?
When will they start the horn?
What?
That was so ominous.
It's so ominous.
Scary.
No sleep for you.
Not today.
Jobless.
Suddenly starting to feel like we're playing regular Minecraft.
This village is useless.
I'm literally nothing.
Not even a crafting table.
Take the bell.
Can I?
Whoa.
It's just like a...
Giant stage in the sky.
Everyone's unemployed because of the cult.
Clearly.
Let's go to the other side of the village.
I suppose.
And then...
We'll go...
Die in battle.
Oh good.
There's more...
Whoa.
There's some more...
Bread.
Yes.
I think bread will be our fastest, easiest way to get food right now.
They haven't even cooked any...
They haven't grown anything.
This village is crazy.
There's so much going on.
Bread.
Bread, bread, bread.
More bread.
Bread.
I'm not ignoring.
Please don't sound the horn.
I don't...
I don't know what that means.
I don't know what the horn means.
Boy.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Oh, pull butt load.
Let's go.
Just one moment, please.
Give me a second.
More bread.
Give me a moment.
I'm collecting my thoughts.
I'm preparing myself for battle.
I'm doing my ritual.
Bread.
Oh wait.
Is it wheat?
Okay.
Nice.
And then...
Bread.
I need a crafting table for bread!
What was that building?
This one?
This is like the little church, I guess you call it.
Wait.
I can just steal your wood.
Thank you!
Can I eat these?
Nice.
Do they provide me anything?
No.
This village has actually nothing.
Hello.
I...
Emeralds!
Oh, gosh.
Scared me.
I don't have...
I'm broke.
I'm actually broke.
I've got absolutely nothing.
Wait a second.
If I can make...
A...
A bucket.
I could get the lava.
That could be something to kill him, no?
Right?
Maybe?
Stick to Emerald.
Is that what he...
Did he take that?
Stick to Emerald!
What was I going to do with this again?
What was I making?
Oh!
A crafting table.
And now...
We make some bread.
The most bread we've ever had in our life.
Okay.
Warden is immune to lava.
Oh, is he?
Lava bath?
Would it work?
It could.
It might.
Who knows?
I think it's worth a try.
Bucket.
Because...
We only have three.
That's all we got, baby.
That's all we've got!
I think he's immune to lava.
Time to try!
Oh.
The warden is immune.
Good day to you all.
Good day, good day.
And good night.
See you all...
Never again.
Oh, I see the exit, even, too.
Unless it's...
I have no confidence in winning this, which is why I'm not grabbing, like...
You know...
Beat.
Or anything like that.
I just kind of want to see how this goes.
To be honest.
I'm just curious what's gonna happen.
I'm just kind of winging it, baby.
Look, it shows the exit right over there, but I can't tell if that's the stage or...
Oh, yeah.
It's the stage.
It's all right.
Oh, yeah.
It's the stage.
When will they start the fight?
I don't know.
Stop saying that.
I hear him sleeping.
Double...
Trump still looks weird.
Me, too.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
Wait.
Do I go inside?
This is so weird.
I'm just gonna use this.
He died.
He died of cringe.
Let's get some more...
Hold on.
I'm just gonna make a...
shovel real quick.
So I can get some...
dirt.
Wait, no.
You think I...
No, I can hear him literally snoring.
There's no way that I won.
I hear him snoring.
There's no way.
That's him snoring.
He's snoring.
He's snoring right now.
See?
Oh, see?
He's right there.
What's the door over there for?
What?
Storage.
I want to try it again because there was, like, that room that had, like, heads and stuff in it.
I want those.
Ouch.
Sad.
Any door over here?
Oh.
Sad.
Okay.
You ran a bit far.
The boss deloaded in the exit spot.
This is...
This is not possible.
This is not happening.
Whoa!
Okay.
Wait a second, then.
Hold on.
What's in here?
Bring this to the...
Get experience.
Oh.
Whoa!
I missed all this stuff in here.
Wait, what's this?
Um.
Oh, turns lights on?
For what?
Music disc.
Tone-Death Rebellion.
Artemis, thank you so much for the 20th.
Is this one going to get copyrighted from?
What do you build here?
Oh!
What is going on?
This is like a circus.
What's happening?
It's so loud.
Shut up.
God.
Is this part of the fight?
Or...
Use the lava.
I don't have it anymore.
Oh.
Oh, it's an instant exit.
Oh, okay.
That's what that is.
Well, that was...
Something.
Hold on.
Hold!
Your horses.
I want to go out like a man.
Yes.
And...
Uh...
I wish I could get the more arrows.
Chopper.
You know what?
I'm going to get that too.
Because why not?
Six levels.
Whatever.
Okay.
I want...
I want to...
I want to check it out!
And see what goes on!
You have to prepare the stage first...
And wake the boss up to fight him.
I...
Warden hurts?
What happened to you?
He's awake?
Wait, why is he awake?
Wait.
How is he alive right now?
Uh-oh.
Um...
Wait.
I think...
My game...
Oh, he's awake inside the thing.
Okay.
He takes notice.
Uh-oh.
But I'm...
I'm sneaking!
Put all the armor on you, right?
Why is he alive?
Uh-oh.
I did say...
The villagers make noise.
That's how it's supposed to be.
Ah, I see.
Are they going to kill him?
Or is he going to kill them?
Oh, shoot!
I died.
If I go back in...
It was sadly lost.
Oh, my God!
Look at all my stuff!
Oh, God.
When it starts getting dark...
Okay.
So, this is how it's supposed to be.
Ah!
I'm passing!
Chicken jockey!
Ah!
Thank you, everybody.
For...
For more craft mine today.
This is fun.
Um...
Goodness gracious.
I have another stream today with Dookie Bird.
I will be on her channel.
I don't know if I can say the whole time.
So, she might have to be extra brave today to get through everything.
So that we can get through the chapter.
Because I have, like I said, I have my meeting with the 3D studio tonight.
So, it's important.
Yeah.
Yeah, Dookie Bird.
So, um...
We're going to have to make sure she's extra brave today.
Okay, guys?
If you're going to come watch...
I stream a POV?
No, no.
It's a one-player game.
So, uh...
Yeah.
It's on her channel.
It's just, uh...
I'm just there for moral support, pretty much.
Anyway!
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
And, uh...
And...
Rate her waiting room.
Oh, I guess we can do that, right?
Let me put it up.
So, for anybody who wants to watch...
Um...
Dookie Bird.
Oh, she does have a waiting room up.
Okay, perfect.
Wingmaid.
Yeah.
Thanks for having us.
Craftmine is a blast.
And, yeah.
It will be fun to see how Dookie deals.
I don't know how many more Craftmines I'll do.
Um...
I don't know.
Maybe every once in a while.
I probably won't do them weekly.
Maybe just, like, kind of when I feel like it.
We can do a Craftmine.
When I don't know...
What to play.
So, yeah.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
And I'll see you later.
Bye-bye.